[Music]
and so bad it's good news oh that's good
no it's like when I discovered my salad
is better all the time I've seen her
joking around he said that she's Bo but
that didn't happen but did it happen I'm
too sensitive so she can't jerk me off
she has to comb it
[Laughter]
yeah what do you mean like home show me
the motion of what it means it's what do
you mean I just want to be honest like
you're on trial nobody even asked you
know why cuz I'm real and there's too
much fake [ __ ] going on in social that's
what I'm saying it's so bad cuz you
don't want to admit it cuz you feel
shame but it's okay it's junk food okay
I shouldn't say junk food junk food
ariana grande is being criticized for
her questionable tour merch well you'll
probably like this where she have a
dildo black clothes so did you nice nope
they're comparing this to how iconic
Britney Spears tour club merch was back
in 2018 where fans of the fan club were
the only ones that could get the merch
and they had to pay 40 bucks to get an
exclusive tour shirt and then it was it
was hold on
oh the computer froze I'm just gonna
show you it's Mercury retrograde this
was Britney Spears shirt I can't see my
thing
Nikki make it brighter why is your
computer so dark I forgot that it was
dark no that's your keyboard Oh Nikki
was really bright now there you go alien
oh this whole time yo I'm not TIF
okay so Britney Spears tour merch was
like this and it was like so bad that it
was good like people were like look oh
that's what they meant you know that's I
paid forty bucks for this and I had to
buy tickets to her yeah yeah okay so
Ariana greenie Spears is in Las Vegas
yeah she is
Jesus man he only has like a like 50
million dollars in it she won that one
we should have a wall cuz I'd have a lot
of gold stickers there there's no grades
mr. dad man
dude that was actually me I got gold
stickers but bad grades I always wanted
the [ __ ] if you get like five or
something you get the scratches and
sniff Joe that's wonderful maybe you
could win one of Ariana Grande's shirts
these are her recent shirts for her tour
but she is actually charging money for
some really weird designs and then some
fans notice that this one look a stain
it looks like a dick print we're [ __ ]
Captain Hook right here it looked like
those cups like that cup company that
has it looks like you just you put you
put laundry in and you put tide and it's
soaked on the shirt that's what it looks
like horrible marriage by the way if
you're buying tore merch anyways it's
it's [ __ ] tour merch
you know I mean like I've never bought
tour March because I liked the way it
looked I just [ __ ] with the arms oh yeah
Kanye's good music won that with the
angel you know what though I'll tell you
what I bought that [ __ ] again yo dis
shit's dope as [ __ ] because it had the
Goyle or the the gold foil print on it
I watched it once that's all I'm saying
is it's like even if it's dope or it
wasn't I still would have got it just
because I went through the tour so like
was about the tour yeah so for me like
if I'm [ __ ] with the artist no matter
what it is I'm still gonna get it yeah
has to be 40 bucks like I went to the
Conner kabhi fight and it was the
ugliest shirt I've ever seen but it
still paid 40 bucks for it
mm-hmm this is more like a memorable yes
memorabilia then and they do it the
cheapest way possible because they
trying to exactly cheat you that's on a
guild and t-shirt for sure yeah
yeah this is like this that shit's a
hundred dollars that's what one fan said
oh my god okay now we're just oh [ __ ]
Julia and they charge them more for
shipping that's it's seven that one yeah
they're all the rest of them are
sixty-five seventy holy [ __ ] yeah that
one's like a hundred bucks [ __ ] with
the Schick stain damn mm-hmm but you do
know it's not her call right like it's
her whole team doing long no it's
Ariana's fault
yeah the ones that orchestrating this
whole thing if she knew I don't know if
she'd be like this it looks more like a
dick oh yeah like when it's cut off like
that it does yeah this is what I got but
it's like but that's what you got yeah
don't give them the money to see so bad
it's good it's like oh my god I can't
possibly why did you buy it and then go
complain about it's like a mystery you
choose but yeah selection of clothing
the selection of merch that you could
choose from is like this is one of the
other things that you could choose it's
like it's with many people of like early
2000s delia catalogs like what is that
what am i looking at what's the inside
of a [ __ ] tangerine peel that's what
they're you can't complain if you chose
it like if it was a mystery box thing
and it's like oh we're gonna surprise no
one's forcing you to buy it
exactly yeah that's what I always feel
about this to it it's like nobody's
forcing you to buy it 100% like you
could look that like that's ugly move on
yeah yeah it's like I'll just keep the
ticket stub what is this is this like
Laberge booth at the cops yeah oh okay
so it's not like VIP and then you also
get a t-shirt no no that's it this is
that's why it's so expensive yeah it's
like 65 bucks that [ __ ] from the merch
booth and it's not next to the $10 beer
oh yeah because it's look
so bad that they're like I gotta get
that [ __ ] yeah and and they want to have
merch because they like this there's no
options of anything good know exactly
see the thing I don't understand is like
when this amount of money is being spent
planning such a like I guess big tour
world tour how are you gonna skimp on a
graphic designer who's designing this
[ __ ] right right like come on man you're
making millions of dollars off this [ __ ]
just off the merch and it's not even
that much money to make it better it's
just a little bit nice yeah so
negligently like the increase in price
but they do should like this day it's
fashionable and people don't really
understand it either cuz it's like it's
like on this on this shirt
it just says like it's like a squiggle
all right and then it just says like
someone poor tight at the bottom it just
says like randomly it says USA here and
then Europe with like some fingerprints
across it what if they get it like from
chart like like they get a China
catalogue and they're like which ones
are the cheapest and you're not selling
okay to like something in her video or
her album halter fans aren't picking up
on it [ __ ] James Cage white design
yeah oh that's so sad these are a
special friend he who doesn't even know
use the world world he knows I exist
he's my friend he follows me he talks to
me and on top of that he retweeted my
picture I had a friend like she comments
on me and then I comment I have you know
who called me cutie who sizzler that's
pretty crazy
take advantage of that get some sizzling
coupons I had to throw it out there cuz
yours was pretty cool and I wanted to be
just a school it's cool because it's
like that meal that you got like so for
something special for when you were a
kid you know like I remember sizzler
used to be good yeah yeah in the salad
bar I would dream of that that's where I
was bred to like says it was good
because like marketing was really great
for children and we were the kids yeah
plus you could get the soft serve ice
we couldn't get that anywhere else all I
know is that it's been so incepted into
my mind no matter what I still like
zidler like it's just because that's I
haven't been the Hometown Buffet you
know what I crave it I do too I'm not
the fried chicken the hotel the man man
anything at home tell evade it's all
about the cockroaches too
you can make your own ice cream
sandwiches with the cookies yeah we used
to steal the cookies we serve agent
style wrap them up in a napkin I do I
know you do for M&M yeah but yeah he
wears a lot of Rick and Morty I have
some Rick and Morty fan stuff too well
like when you go to a concert or when
you go to an event do you end up buying
that I pretty much do every single time
just because I'm like I want to support
the artist I'm there and then also like
it's like you only get that merch if you
were there that's true or if you buy it
off eBay or somebody like stuff that I
[ __ ] with a lot if they put it on some
type of clothing I almost immediately
want yeah exactly yeah so like with the
but the problem with I have is that a
lot of people just put too much of that
[ __ ] everywhere so it's too apparent
right so like I [ __ ] with like Winnie
the Pooh right but if they had like a
Winnie the Pooh like jean jacket is [ __ ]
but they just put that little honeypot
like a little bit smaller right do you
have that like really small not like a
hella big [ __ ] yeah yeah my mom has like
this you know like those that fake denim
yeah like that thing that it's like a
shirt but people wear it
Oh Sean Bray no I think it's did take a
teeny like a button-up yeah yeah yeah
weird over I don't [ __ ] that yeah she
has it see I want this year
okay I could have sworn I seen yeah yeah
yeah at the Disney Store
so bad it's good I don't know I I guess
this objective some people might look at
that and be like you know this [ __ ] is
dope I think a lot of people are on the
our side it's still rocket like honestly
if I was an ariana fan I'd be like [ __ ]
it I mean I'm gonna support you and also
I was there [ __ ] spent over $100 on a
Michael Jackson jacket that was like as
thin as a [ __ ] long sleeve t-shirt
that's true he wore this not wear that
[ __ ] for I could you spend $100 but it
that's like 100 into Vegas to wear to
another shop oh yeah you ready got your
money back that's a good man
[Music]
[Music]